I remember Krulwich. I'm Molly Webster. This is radio lab.
And this week Jad is off nestled into his office working on the next episode,
which will play with a lot of the ideas that came up in our,
in our last Gary Hart podcast. But like with pop stars in music, meantime,
we've decided to offer you guys a little Valentine's treat.
It's gonna be part prose, part musical in a hip hop sort of way, uh,
with some extremely cool guests. Really well, I promise you. Yes.
At the end of the show and it all grows out of a tail.
We heard about a very small animal,
which begins appropriately with a very small noise.
Yeah. So, so in, in days gone by,
people tended to die at home.
This is go back a couple of hundred years before that, our hospitals and so on.
This by the way, is David Gulson.
I'm a professor of biology at the University of Sussex in the UK and he told
this tale to producer lots of NASA. And I said, imagine that,
that Tina grandpa's l and it looks like he might die soon.
I started to know why that's funny. But uh, and so he,
so he'd be lying in bed upstairs and everyone would be, we'd be out of respect,
would be very quiet, you know, there'd be creeping around the highest,
it was a time called the death watch. And when everyone was really quiet,
they'd hear these faint and drumming noises coming from the,
from the timbers of the house.
[inaudible]
I can try and do an impression of the noise that, yeah, we'd love to hear.
You may not work very well, but, but bear with me. Yeah.
Okay.
Did you get that? Yeah. Yeah.
So five or six identical beats and,
and legend has it,
but that was the devil drumming his fingers impatiently waiting for the soul to
depart the body so that he could claim it.
But turns out actually it's the mating call of a tiny little beetle.
Okay.
The death watch beetle, that's where it gets its name.
So Dave became a kind of a fan of these Beatles. Oh yeah.
It's the widespread species in your hand. In fact,
he's got a house that's full of it,
ate pretty decrepit as it's slightly falling down the roof leaks and uh,
and whatever. But it's, it's home to a whole host of these little beetles
bet.
And in the quiet he can hear them.
So a while ago he found himself wondering,
what's this noise really all about at which you might not think would be a great
mystery. Um, but what he discovered is it's all about
love or at least sex.
So today, a story that reminds us how difficult,
lonely, how hard
the meeting game can be.
Perfect. Valentine's Day.
So we will begin at the beginning of the life cycle. Yeah.
So, so the female beetle lays an egg on that, on, on a, uh, a piece of deadwood.
He would watch them and the moms would just, you know, drop their babies random.
Oh yes, I'm here. Some,
they're usually into a hole in a log or into a wood beam and it hatches into the
little tiny white grub. So you might have this little thing, your pitch black,
you know, and its own little tunnel on its own. I need starts chewing.
Uh, I choose the way the wood very, very slowly
and eventually about 10 or 15 years later,
years later, 15 years, yeah.
For a decade or more for things. Um,
and eventually it reaches the magnificent size of about a quarter of an inch,
uh, at which point [inaudible] eight p pite so it turns into a little,
a little Chrysalis and, uh, a few months later, the adult beetle
hatches out of that.
And so finally it crawls out of the log and onto the surface.
[inaudible]
is that the first time they see light? Yeah, Yup. That will be it.
Oh Wow. So they say any of the adults that you ever really see, um,
and they possibly the most boring looking insects you could imagine.
They're about a quarter of an inch long bullet shaped dull brown. Um, they,
they really easily mistaken for mice droppings actually. And the,
the adult only has really one job and that's to mate. So the male below,
he has to find himself a female.
So he's got his work cut out for one thing as an adult. He, he doesn't eat,
he can't feed. So he's going to starve to death in a couple of weeks or so.
On top of that. He's nearly blind. Yeah. Uh,
and that's where this strange drumming noise comes in.
That's their way of finding each other in the, in,
in the usually rather dark places where they live. That's your way of saying
hello. Hello.
Yeah. And they make it by drumming their head. So the male Beatles,
he kind of braces himself and then he wax his head five, six times in. Oh,
you say drumming the head. You mean banging the head? Yeah,
he's like headbutts the, the, the,
the timber he's sitting on where these kinds of forehead if you like.
So that's what makes the drumming note.
He's basically whacking his head against that, against the wood. So
[inaudible]
he comes out of his hole,
um,
just one does a bat
and does his little drumming noise. Now,
if a human happens to hear him, people these days,
they tend to spray their houses with insecticides and that's the end of the
Beatles.
Oh. But yeah,
let's assume you, yes. Let's assume that he doesn't get fumigate. Okay.
He just keeps wondering about banging his head and he pauses for a second,
kind of listening to see if anyone replies. And there's no, there's no reply.
One design.
Unfortunately, according to David Death,
folks beetles are quite rare these days.
So there is a distinct chance the pull mail will never find a female. Ah,
this just gets more and more depressing. They pretty sorry, I'm laughing.
Um, and can you tell the same story from the, from the female's perspective?
Yes. Yes. She just, she just sort of is.
She just waits in silence for three weeks and if no one comes, she just,
she just started, this kills. Everyone dies. Yeah, she does what?
She wanders around a little bit,
I suppose in the hope that she might encounter a male. But that's, that's,
that is all she does. So that's a tedious life, I'm afraid.
But let's imagine again, for the sake of argument,
that after the 15 years of chewing and no fumigation for them at all,
they lets them think, wow. They get really lucky. He gets a reply,
they find each other,
she makes the noise immediately after she hears the cry of a, of a male.
Yeah. And he gets,
Ben gets very excited cause he may have been wondering about banging his head
for four days and this little duet gets going. He starts to run a rind,
banging his head over and over again. Yeah. This is the, this is,
this is his moment. And eventually by a lot of trial and error,
and occasionally they got it wrong and fell off the edge and were never seen
again. But more often than not, he would eventually find the female and,
uh, the males will immediately jump on, on top of her.
And he then continues to draw me his head.
But this time he's not headbutting the temporaries. He's whacking her, um,
which, which I mean each to their own, you know,
presumably that works for a female death watch beetle.
But because they're very short sighted,
they will often jump on the wrong way round. And, and that's,
that's not so good. Um, because the females can actually control,
like he can't force them to mate. So he has to persuade her to,
to cooperate or else he's going nowhere and then he can humans tell them it's
going well. Well, so you usually, she, she carries on replying.
So she, he's banging her in the back of her head and she's,
she is then drumming her head on the wood underneath and that's usually a good
sign that you, if she carries on banging her head on the, on the timber,
that that means she's probably going to make with them in the,
in within the next minute or two.
But they've says when he has watched this happen,
he's noticed that quite often the females wouldn't make,
even though you know that maybe you've been sitting there for days waiting for a
partner to come along.
And then when one finally does and he finally gets to them,
they're not interested. You know, it's not good. They weren't,
they only have three weeks. That is so shocking to me.
This is a very discerning lady that she chooses death over an ugly mate.
Well, I guess she's not actually Ci. She's hoping that she'll get a better mate.
There's another fish in the sea, another efficiency hopefully. But I thought,
well, what's the difference? Why are some males successful in some not?
And it quickly became clear that the heavier the male,
the more likely he was to be successful.
So is there some explanation for why? So actually these things, they,
they produce quite staggering amounts of sperm. It turns like, Whoa,
what is standard? What do you mean by staggering?
The average was 13% of his body weight. 13%.
So I mean, what if that were us? Like what would that be like?
We were talking about three or four gallons. So, um, you know,
think about that from Roger's best. Not to think about that too much really, but
it's a slightly disturbing.
So the deep tragedy here would be to be a member of this species and to be born,
scrawny, scrawny. Yeah. I mean, just out of curiosity, I just, how big are you?
Um, I'm moderately skinny, so please love me. I'd be in trouble anyway.
Um, so what I'd,
what I really wanted to know where the females actually just weighing in the
males or was it something that was correlated with being a big male, you know,
maybe they were stronger or made a lighter noise or something. And so,
so the obvious way to try and find out was to artificially change the weight of
the males to make tiny fat suits for the well, exactly. Yeah.
Not Quite, but, um, I wish this worked for people. That would be hilarious,
but I don't think it does. Um,
so we have this stuff called blue tack in the UK.
Do you have blue tack over there? I don't know, but it's not like sticky tack,
sticky tack. I guess.
He used to stick posters on the wall and so Dave went to the store,
bought some of this stuff and then just beat it up into little bits and stuck
them on the back of, of males to make them a little bit heavier.
And for the skinny males, it worked an absolute treat.
I do feel slightly mean that, uh,
those poor females obviously were getting a bit shortchanged, but, uh,
hopefully they managed to produce some eggs anyway because in the end they find
these beetles, the males and the females, surprisingly charming. And after all,
he does live with them. A lot of them, they are still in my house.
They're still chewing away at the beans. I, I been, I'm torn, you know,
part of me knows that if I don't spray them as some insecticide,
then eventually the roof will start to collapse. But it's gonna take decades.
And I kind of quite like having there. So, so for the moment I,
they've been spared and uh, uh,
I can't quite like listening to them tapping away in the springtime.
So you're sitting in bed at dawn or dusk and you hear the quiet banging and you
think, yeah, yeah. It's, it's, it's funny, isn't it,
that people thought this was a sinister noise and actually it's,
it's all about love.
[inaudible]
thank you to Dave Golson who wrote a book all about these bugs,
a buzz in the meadow, the natural history of French farm. Oh wait, this is,
I didn't mention to you that it's a French farm.
He has this little place in France that he goes to one month a year and that's
where he communes with his beetle friends and has one of the saddest months.
Thank you. I thought this drug is terribly sad.
I found it. It made me think that dating in New York was pretty easy,
right? For people who are feeling, if you're feeling said,
we want to end that problem right away. In the next part of this show,
we're going to revisit this story in such a crazily new way for us.
Um, the guys from Hamilton, the hot Broadway show,
I told some of them this story that you just heard and they have decided to um,
to musicalize the tail and they will do that right after this brief pause.
But Oh, before, while, during the pause, you know how Raunchy this story is?
Well, it only gets more so when it's in the musical towel.
So you might want to ask your, your little ones to, uh,
leave the room around now.
And then you should by all means stay for the after party.
This is Melanie calling from Durham, North Carolina.
Radiolab is supported in part by the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science and technology and the modern world.
More information aboutSloan@wwwdotsloan.org
I'm Robert Krulwich. I'm Molly Webster. This is act two in which I, you know,
when I put together these, any story as you know,
I just wander around and tell it to every single person I know as I'm sure you
do it. All right. So yeah, it could be strangers.
And so I was talking to a friend of mine who's a in the theater named guy named
Tommy Kale. And I'm talking to him and I'm thinking,
I'm wondering what's going on in the minds of these little,
assuming that they have mines, these little animals. Cause it seems so unfair.
15 years issuing and then this. So he said, you know, we could be those beetles.
We, who's the we built,
we is an improvisational freestyle group called Freestyle Love Supreme.
And it's now this, I should tell you what the Tommy goes to Lin Manuel Miranda,
who's no joke, who is Hamilton in the hit musical Hamilton. And he writes,
he says, I'll be one of the Beatles. And then they go to Oak Tosh, uh, Ambedkar,
who was in a movie called pitch perfect when he played a rapper. And by the way,
this is all guys like this is like you have to think of himself as in,
in an Elizabethan Beatles situation. This is Shakespearean watch beetle.
That's right. All the lady Pi's will be played by mail,
but Lynn's going to be the woman and is going to be the man.
So here is the mail beetle being the beetle that he hopes he can be.
Hey ladies,
also the way to Zolpha get ready for the beautiful Beto Casanova.
He is I and I am him.
The most masculine Beto by the name of slim net evolution made me small.
So Walker slipped through the cracks.
I'll be the first one to jump on on lady beetles back.
But it's hard out here when I'm not playing the human beings here, Megan,
and they get the sprayer. They think that I'm the devil,
so they get a few [inaudible]. They don't understand that I'm only procreate in,
but I'm slimmer, so I'm a winner. I finally see the sun people, shorty.
I know that she the one, so I'm like, Vito, baby doll. Let's get involved.
I want to give it to you all right here on this low.
Have you want to do that with my entire life and feels so good to finally find a
wife? Yeah, I get routine. I'm your chosen,
but can you remind me which end it goes in?
Goes in, goes in. This is hard. Yeah, but right out there for a beetle,
but for the female played by Lin Miranda. I mean,
she's going to have her own agenda. She needs to find a guy. It has to be.
She hopes it will be the best guy, but I don't know.
Sound byte is knocking. Could this be
[inaudible] Ben, is this amazing?
Wait in my Mama told me to never said I was did is,
I was terrible.
I'm looking for Hattie with the body for the sperm and deep doubt,
a heart of gold.
But when you hear that knocking and it's a sound, sorry,
this is the grass was green there. Was there a heavier of song?
Sound bad snacking. But I am a beetle worth waiting.
I'm going to wait for something. Whoa.
The power of the female and the sadness for the guy. But this is
Valentine's Day. No, I'm sweating.
Lame Dude. And she's like, Oh my God,
I've waited 15 years for this and I can't do it with you and she has to move on
and fall off the table.
Okay? Okay. But now you know that professor Goulston is our cupid.
Here he is right after effects. Save both of our sad souls. Yes,
with the sticky tackle. Here is the, this is the kind of a lame,
validated carbon. I'm thinking about it,
but here is our finish to our own Valentine's tail,
little Romeo and Juliet Ish. Actually.
Again, I'm going to make you mark at the end of the day.
I'm half blind. Where are you? Fine. Here you are. You're, wait a minute.
I bet you will know my life long to put the work in veto, baby dog.
Don't let me die a virgin.
I'm Sur in the love of burn like embers of the one and only love.
Keep banging your head on the timber. I agree. It'd be easier with Tinder,
but let me lose
[inaudible] give you some of my beetle juice saw. Loves knocking. Okay.
I know it was playing it cool before, but seriously,
I got no clue what I'm doing. So if you could help me out,
you'd be doing me a real solid. You found your way to me.
Little did she know before I beat it. The doctor helped me achieve
slim, Windsor and
dead. Then what a way to go.
Whoa.
Okay. It is time, of course, for us to go. Thanks.
Especially to freestyle love supreme into the question.
I'm a car otherwise known as u t k to Thomas Kale and to Lin Manuel Miranda and
to our producers on this episode, Soren Wheeler and Simon Adler. Thank you.
Thank you. I'm Robert Krulwich. I'm Molly Webster and Happy Valentine's Day.
Happy Valentine's Day, Robert. Yeah, you too.